and so we actually found this one you
may not have seen this before how they
got buried it kind of got back kind of
like long-lost historically I don't
think people were on at archives law I
alert it wasn't archived well at all but
thank God for YouTube we have Bob Ross
your favorite public broadcaster amazing
painter and we found this episode of the
joys of painting right teaches you how
to draw Muhammad
[Music]
I welcome to joy of painting I'm happy
to see you here today especially on this
week cultural appropriation month as we
appreciate the wonderful culture that is
the Middle East and our Muslim friends
it's always good to have friends of many
different walks of life so today we're
gonna be teaching you how to draw a nice
picture in a landscape of Muhammad peace
be upon him the holiest of prophets so
let's show you how to start you got to
get your paint ready I prefer to use
oils you could use pastels it's whatever
you pick painting can be easy for
anybody let's just pick a nice neutral
color and we are going to just start
drawing Mohammed a little prophet there
let me grab a color there we go just
give him a body a little bit of a body
there Sikh doesn't have to be complex
traditional headdress they wear in the
Middle East let's give this let's give
this man a beard there we go
nice beard for Mohammed it protect your
face in the sandstorms beard is
important to have and there we go give
him some facial features see little
details see how that fills out the
picture now Mohammed oh look at him he
looks lonely how about we give him a
wife let's just draw him little wife
favorite one was Ayesha a little 6 year
old wife right there we'll put her in
the jab not the full burqa you can
choose your favorite color for the head
Jabbar burka can be black or slate and
little six-year-old Asia you know what
let's give her a knapsack she's about
that age where she'll go to school
Ayesha Muhammad's favorite wife was six
nine when he consummated she was a good
student and a tender lover look at that
see look very quickly we have Ayesha
Mohammed what a cute couple but he still
seems a little lonely let's give him a
few more wives just a few more wives
these ones don't have to be complex
Kenny can use black her
right let's give them the full burqa
there you go and a couple more wives
just a couple more wives to keep them
company
one two three of course he had more you
can draw as many as you want use the
color you want Mohammed lacked some
foliage let's draw some trees for him
I'm using a forest green you could use a
you could use a military green because
he was a warlord killed lots of
Christians and Jews didn't like him very
much there we go
just some foliage some trees let's give
some there on the other side of Mohammed
there let's get just a little bit of
green oh that's nice see Mohammed was
really clear that should never hurt the
trees the time of war was very concerned
with the plants not so much with his
wife so let's give Ayesha a little bit
of a black eye I think that's her next
step
Mohammed of course did strike a shoe but
only lightly causing her great pain
let's put black either I'm using moe you
can use violet you just want to make
sure people see the severe beating
Ayesha took you know what let's get a
crimson red in there give little
six-year-old Ayesha a student lover a
fat lip that's Muhammad's wife who he
beat he's drawn right there so you can
see the left of her and there we go
Ayesha with a black eye and a fat lip oh
look at that picture out there in desert
lonely nights the finest even look what
we were able to draw here just a couple
of minutes painting doesn't have to be
hard especially when your inspiration is
Mohammed the holiest of prophets who
like to beat a six-year-old wife didn't
hurt trees but I had lots of lives
didn't like Jews I hope you've enjoyed
it have a good week and happy painting
[Music]
hey you're still here that's surprising
I'm not going to lie this is the
Internet most people have an attention
span of four seconds but this is the
clip taken from the full weekly
videocast podcast you can click below to
watch that full video cast or subscribe
on iTunes or SoundCloud click my face
little otter with credit com where there
are more articles than you could read in
a lifetime or click below me where
there's another video it's shorter
because I know you're busy and you have
things to do like find pants